it's amazing to me that Avril Lavigne
when she was 16 years old writes
Breakaway and says gee I don't want to
sing that I'm going to give it to Kelly
Clarkson and you have this huge hit well
and I'm like I want to say to Avril why
would you do that well I gotta own
something yeah go ahead so
I like the song okay I'm gonna lead with
that
but I'm gonna be honest with you my
label was like look if you do this we'll
give you this and so like with songs on
the record so I like the song I just
didn't feel like it fit it like if you
listen to the rest of that album it
doesn't sound anything like Breakaway
like you know like really listen to
Behind These Hazel Eyes or since you've
been gone or because of you or walk away
like all those songs sound nothing like
this Vibe so I just didn't think it fit
in and so I'm gonna give the label this
one they were really like pushing for it
and I was like man if y'all really
believe in it all right I was like I
like country music and I actually feel
like it's the most country song I've
ever heard from avrilo it's actually a
country song to me so it's not it's not
like that's why I felt like it just
didn't fit I love country music but like
I just didn't feel like it fit in with
the record but and then we ended up
naming it
this is one of your biggest hits one of
the biggest hits too because it was on
the princess diaries two soundtracks so
it's like yeah but I wanted to promote
some music you know do you think she
ever like after this became a big hit do
you think she sits there and goes why
the [__] did I give that to Kelly
Clarkson no I think she's like I didn't
even have to do that and I'm making so
much money right she's the one who gets
paid yeah right so much success like and
I don't think she thinks about that at
all did you call her after the thing
went to number one no I didn't I we've
uh talked to each other because she's
been on my show
um right but I'm kind of known for
covering not only other songs but like
even for my record like pink wrote
broken and beautiful and Katy Perry
wrote I do not hook up and uh long shot
and Christina Aguilera is one of the
writers
um uh with myself on Miss Independent
like I I cover I don't care who writes
it like I think a lot of artists will be
intimidated by that they're like oh I
have to write my own music I won't write
you know whatever right great song is a
great song so I and I love supporting
other females especially great writers
like those ladies
oh